foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
hello hello
[Music]
[Applause]
hi hello everyone and welcome so please
find your seat if you haven't already
because we are just about to begin
um
foreign
ceremony here within the European
Parliament in Brussels my name is I am a
film journalist and I am from Belgium
and I am Ellie mastoro I am a film
journalist also and I am from Greece
anyone from Greece in the room with us
tonight
yes yes
so we will we will both serve as your
masters of ceremony for the next hour we
will guide you through this very last
step towards the revealing of the looks
audience Award winner we know that in
the past few months many of you have
been sharing and uh voting for your
favorite films out of the films that are
nominated this year which are five and
we're excited to reveal the winner I
know I am how about you Ellie definitely
Stan I can't hardly wait but before we
begin some technical details so first
interpretation is available to you if
you want to follow the ceremony in one
of the official EU languages please look
around and the number of the channel
corresponding to the language you want
is indicated right there you can also
follow the ceremony online through the
website of the European Parliament that
is
multimedia.europal.europa.eu but also
through the social media challenge
channels like uh Facebook Instagram for
instance so we will very shortly be
joined by representatives of each each
of the five films nominated tonight
namely with us we have director Carla
Simon for the film alcaraz so yes
[Applause]
yes so I personally thought about my
grandparents watching this film I don't
know if you did too but I did yes we
also have with us director Emin Alpert
for burning days
felt really thirsty under the scorching
heat of burning days was I the only one
no no no I can tell you it was Heavy yes
we see Hands raised so uh we also have
with us director Lucas Dawn for his film
clothes
yes raise your hand if you shed a tear
raise your hand if you cried during
clothes because I know I needed tissues
yes yes I was not the only one I can see
that also with us the actress Sunni
melons for triangle of sadness
[Applause]
I'm I'm guessing I'm guessing many of
you saw the film and I want to know
after watching it who is going to try a
cruise ship after watching triangle of
sadness
nope nope no not me and last but not
least we have director joao Pedro
Rodriguez for his film Willard whisp
[Applause]
so films need inspiring directors and in
a way so does the European Parliament
in a few seconds we will be joined by
three inspiring leaders of the European
Parliament the president of the European
Parliament herself Mrs Roberta metzola
the vice the Vice President in charge of
the Lux audience award Mrs Evelyn Regner
and the chair of the committee on
culture and education Mrs Sabine Varian
so we are really excited for the
presence at the 16th edition of The Lex
award can you believe it's been 16 years
already I know 16 years and back when it
was created it used to be called the Lux
prize it had one very big ambition from
the start to use European films and
there are many diverse stories and
values to bring European citizens closer
together do you remember which film won
the first edition in 2007 yes I do
remember Stan it was the edge of Heaven
by German director fatty Akin a very
moving film about immigration and chosen
families and in those 16 years since the
creation the award has shed light on
other remarkable films such as the
broken Circle breakdown by Felix van
gruningen Tony Hermann by maren other or
last year's winner kovadis Ida by
jazmilla Spanish that's impressive and
shedding light is sure the red
expression since Luke's means site in
Latin but concretely what does it mean
to be for a film to be nominated for the
Lux award well practically it means all
the nominated films are subtitled by
translators of the European Parliament
in the 24 official languages of the
European Union in addition the winner of
the Luxe audience award also gets
adapted for visually and hearing
impaired audiences which is quite
meaningful as for film success it makes
it so much easier for the film to be
accessible in all European countries and
on top of that the European Parliament
officers in the EU countries have
organized for this edition of a 500 free
screenings for over 50 000 people wow
okay that's impressive so the idea is
that European stories need to travel in
order to Foster discussions on European
identity that's the main idea films can
help build and protect democracy and on
this very idea has been the center of
the looks audience award since its whole
evolution
okay so yeah it has surely evolved a lot
because in the beginning only members of
the European Parliament could vote but
today in an effort to build Bridges uh
the vote is split 50 50 between members
of the European Parliament and European
citizens basically just like the
Eurovision yes exactly and believe it or
not this year was the biggest
participation from citizens so far can
you guess how many votes were cast yes I
can guess it was over 45
000 ratings spread among the five
nominees so it's an absolute record
please yes we can we can applaud that
so so basically we can observe democracy
in action oh that's convenient that's
exactly the tagline of next year's
European election stand that's very
clever
so we're getting closer to the start of
the ceremony but before we'd like to
take a moment to thank all the partners
without whom the Luxe audience award
would not be possible the European film
Academy please stand up you're here with
us tonight
thank you the European commission please
stand up
Cinema Network yes
thank you as well as the selection panel
of the of the European uh of the Lux
representative and is honorary president
Mr Mike Downey
please stand up all right
please please please please please
please I think we're getting there just
like the singer Lisa would say it's
about that time I think you're right so
everyone I would like to please put your
hands together to welcome the president
of the European Parliament Mrs Roberta
metzola
[Applause]
and at her side
[Music]
the representatives of the nominated
films for alcaraz director Carla Simon
[Applause]
[Music]
for clothes for burning days director
Emin Alvar
[Applause]
[Music]
for the movie Close director Lucas don't
and for Willow the Whisk director joao
Pedro Rodriguez
and for triangle of sadness I trust
Sunny mellis yes
yes you can you can keep uploading them
because we're really happy that they're
here and the trophy of course
[Applause]
yes
welcome thank you for being here
good evening everyone
[Applause]
blue lights are nice
good evening so ladies and gentlemen
distinguished guests
welcome
to the Lux audience awards ceremony
We Gather here this evening to celebrate
the great talent and creativity
of European filmmakers
it is an honor to have with us in this
hemicycle the directors actors and
producers of the five films nominated
for this year's Lux audience Awards
you embody the uniqueness of filmmaking
in Europe and your work is acclaimed
internationally
your films have reached hearts and moved
Souls across the world
across language barriers with subtitles
carefully added by European Parliament
translators
over 500 screenings across all member
states
organized by the European Parliament
allowed almost 50 000 people to view
your movies
they have sparked
thought-provoking debates
among members of this Parliament the
film industry professionals and Cinema
lovers alike and your audience's
response has been truly remarkable with
a record number of ratings and this is
evidence that people wholeheartedly
Embrace European Cinema and common
European values presented in these five
nominated films
so when we use the slogan of the Lux
audience awards show your love for
European film
we realize that this has taken on
its true meaning the Lux audience award
is a joint project of the European
Parliament and the European film Academy
organized in partnership with the
European commission and the Europa
Cinemas
the awards promotes European films by
bringing them to audiences far and wide
without language boundaries but it is
also about the issues that filmmakers
bring to the table
about democracy equality
Justice
respect
tolerance and freedom
the film's shed light on pressing
concerns of our time
and they Inspire positive change
they cast light on world events
that mirror Universal societal issues
because through the power of
Storytelling they unite us bringing to
the Forefront shared fundamental
principles of freedom of expression and
dignity
they speak of the struggle of
individuals faced with Injustice
inequality or corruption
with daring honesty these films showcase
the Stark realities of our daily world
and in so doing you remind us that our
work in standing for freedom and
equality is far from complete
and here I would like to thank the
European parliament's committee on
culture and education especially its
committed chair Sabina verhain for her
tireless work in defending and promoting
European cultural diversity artistic
creation and filmmaking
I would also like to thank European
Parliament vice president Evelyn Regner
[Applause]
who is responsible for this award and I
cannot but not mention former member of
this Parliament Doris pack
without room who's here
and without room this award would not
have been possible thank you for making
this Lux Awards audience happen it is a
reward
for all of us
through compelling narratives the five
Lux audience Award nominees Inspire us
to take action in the face of adversity
to challenge the status quo and to be
proponents of change
you invite us to strive for a more
Humane and compassionate world because
together
through Collective effort we can work
towards a future that is better for all
of us and in fact that is also the
message of the European Union project as
a whole United in diversity
together we beat the odds
we weather the storms and come out
stronger that is true for Europe today
warding off multiple crises
the Lux audience award is the only film
price in the world where the audience
votes and picks the winners alongside
members of a democratically elected
Parliament
citizens award the price
democracy in action you decide
this is just like no more than in one
year's time it is citizens who will
decide on the composition of the next
European Parliament at the European
elections you will choose
so ladies and gentlemen
dear friends let's celebrate European
Cinema and the message of hope that
these films carry let's be inspired by
them to participate in positive change
thank you
[Applause]
thank you president metallaffer this
inspiring speech and now I would like to
welcome vice president of the European
Parliament in charge of the Lux audience
award Mrs Evelyn Regner
[Applause]
so
good evening and also from me a warm
welcome to all of you joining us in the
heart of European democracy in the
hemicycle of the European Parliament
this room is a symbolic place yet also
one of action many laws that make our
lives better every single day are voted
and discussed in this room and this is
why it is important to us all that the
democratically elected winner of this
European film prize is announced in our
heart of democracy
why I'm insisting so much on Democracy
during a glamorous film ceremony
because democracy is the very foundation
on which art and life can prosper
yet democracy is under threat
by War by misinformation by social
divides
just 30 years ago Yugoslavia imploded
and collapsed in a Bloody War
the looks winning film of the last year
corvadis Aida showed us how much these
consequences are still being paid today
by everyone today we as European Union
represent the hope
of stability peace and well-being for
many countries negotiating to be part of
the Union not least with Ukraine also
fighting for its independence at the
very same time what we experience in our
Europe could look like an oddly built
house where diversities languages
tradition history and backgrounds are
sometimes difficult to harmonize but let
us not forget this is not only our house
it is our home and our home is what we
make of it
as European Parliament in this building
with so many voices and languages
diversities and variety we are building
this shared home every single day this
very room Echo echoes the voices of all
Europeans thanks to the European
elections and the next ones are less
than a year ahead in June 2024 there is
much at stake so my call to you is to to
take part in the debates engage in the
building of the Europe you want don't
take for granted the peace and
well-being we have
the five nominated films al-karas
burning days
close
triangle of sadness and Willow The
Whisper showing you each in their own
way how current circumstances are
influencing
Our Lives not only members of parliament
voted but many of you did too 45
000 of you and this is the highest
rating ever recorded So this ceremony is
therefore also for you it's a
celebration of participation and
engagement in something fundamental and
at the same time fragile our Cinema and
our cultural heritage
we are here today with our special
guests storytellers directors filmmakers
actors and actresses too who in these
past months allowed us to share emotions
love for European films
all the films chosen for the word are
reminder for us as legislators of the
tasks we have to embrace rights and
inclusion for all the environmental
crisis corruption
and Injustice the histories and
responsibilities of our continents
poverty and inequalities and last but
not least the rights and freedom of
expression
thank you for shedding light on this
with your wonderful films
I'm truly grateful to be in charge of
this award as vice president and to
strengthen this bridge between politics
and culture
so that at the end of the day all of us
can come together to celebrate and to
Stand United in diversity thank you
[Applause]
thank you vice president Regner
so before we welcome Mrs Sabin Varian
chair of the committee of culture and
education we would like to take a moment
to salute some people because we have
with us tonight students and teachers
from all EU countries representing the
European Parliament ambassador's goals
where are you guys say hi
yes thank you thank you for being here
and also with us members of the 27 times
Cinema Network an initiative that brings
together young European cinephiles from
every corner of the U hi guys 27 times
Cinema no over there and thank you for
promoting the Lux audience award
oh
and now I would like you to please
welcome the chair of the committee on
culture and education Mrs Sabine
[Applause]
dear ladies and gentlemen honorable
guests honorable vice president rickner
today we not only celebrate the richness
and diversity of European Cinema but
also our common European values
members of the parliament directors
actors and citizens who all contribute
to the success of this unique experience
which is the Lux audience award we are
all here together in the name of the
European Cinema
we are very lucky to have the
representatives of five European firms
here with us
the films we honor today have collected
the most important prices Awards and
recognitions among the top festivals and
competitions not only in Europe but all
over the world they succeeded to fill
European Cinemas after two long years of
closure
once more the members of the selection
panel for the Lux audience award
succeeded to offer us a pool of films
that are really diverse in the tones the
topics narratives and storytelling
I thank them for their Restless work of
search discover and choice and they
salute their courage
with the luxorians award we as members
of the parliament have explored European
Cinema
it has not always been an easy Journey
as the prize itself that has grown and
evolved very quickly and bravely we have
also learned to watch films we might
have never seen otherwise
we discovered European audiences and
went into a dialogue with them moreover
we have learned that the audience we met
were sometimes more prepared and more
open than us in embracing the proposed
films
we should not underestimate the love our
citizens have for European film
they are the biggest supporters of the
Lux audience award this clearly shows in
the number of ratings that we have
reached this year 45
000 people voting and rating for the
movies
a unique and amazing result a result we
can really be proud of you can be proud
of as audience
another indicator is the numbers of
people that are here with us today
for the very first time the audience is
part of the awards ceremony and so many
joined us today of course not everybody
will love all five films they are just
as diverse as we are as we are in the
European Union however I would like to
make it clear our role is to strongly
defend the freedom of expression and
creativity of artists and storytellers
to ensure that our artists can keep on
portraying the stories they feel
relevant
we will defend our creative Industries
and our creative human capital not only
by fostering European programs and
National measures of support but also
being vigilant in always reacting
against censorship and discrimination
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
thank you
and now the nominees
a Spanish and Italian co-production
Carla Simone invites us under the
catalonian sun to share the joys and
Sorrows of a family of peach farmers
it is a Bittersweet portrait of
generations inspired by the director's
own memories
please welcome director Carla Simone
[Applause]
thank you
hello everyone first of all thank you so
much it's a huge honor to be here today
and also to be part of this amazing
selection of five films for the looks
Awards
is a is a film that portrays a place and
and a job the agricultural job which is
actually my family's job my family
cultivate peaches in alcaraz which is a
village a very small village in
Catalonia in Spain
and I've always think that um
his way of good
imor families is probably the the oldest
job in the world like we've been doing
this or we started doing this in
prehistorical times cultivating the land
in families and I feel that right now
this is something that is in danger
because of the low prices set by big
companies because obviously the climate
change that provokes weather disasters
and in this case these years some
Farmers cannot pick the fruit because of
the lack of water
so we are in a moment I think that we
should really protect the idea of
working in a small I think that this way
of working in a small is really
respectful with the land and also
respectful with the rural areas that we
obviously don't want them to get empty
and it's very funny that with my uncles
we always say that it's very similar
actually the way they cultivate the land
with the way that we actually make
independent cinema somehow like we have
to plant the seed in our case it's an
idea in their case it's a real seed no
we have to water it we have to take care
of it we have to fight the threats
sometimes you know before it actually
comes to light and we can actually pick
a pitch or see a film you know and
independent film I feel sometimes it's
also in danger and I think that in
places like that is where we should
actually try to protect this way of
doing Cinema
in small and also the way of cultivating
the land in small thank you so much
okay
[Music]
our second nominee is burning days a
film made in Turkey with the help of
France Germany Netherlands Greece and
Croatia it's the story of a judge who
arrives in a small town in turkey that
is re-king with corruption it's a
fantastic Thriller but also on a poetic
level it really shows well how polarized
Society can become
please welcome director Emin Alpert
[Applause]
awesome
and this is
[Music]
[Applause]
uh good evening
thank you for coming it's it's a great
honor to be here and uh to be part of
this perfect selection
uh what what drew me to write and shoot
this film it was the rising
authoritarianism in my country
after almost each elections like the
election in the film
we have experienced a trauma-like
feelings because we saw that Rising
authoritarianism corruption destroying
rule of Love violation of Human Rights
and finally a bad management of economy
did not affect the popularity of those
in power
each time
manipulating The Waters by shoving the
minorities namely the Kurds and lgbtq
people as a threat to the majority
strengthening the prejudices of people
in a divided Society
associating the opposition with
terrorists or enemies of the nation
worked out unfortunately
this was achieved by unproportional
power of propaganda acquired by the
monopolyon media
it's a trap which is really difficult to
get out
however
we have to find a way to stop this
irrational wave of authoritarianism
we should be strong we should be clever
diligent be in solidarity and be
courageous to remove this threat to our
freedoms
otherwise the future for us not only in
Turkey but in Europe will be bleak
and our fundamental rights freedoms and
the civilization itself will be in
dangerous
we should do something immediately thank
you
in his second feature close a Belgian
co-production with France and the
Netherlands Lucas don't tell us the
story of two boys linked by an intimate
friendship that will brutally be
disrupted
it is a moving powerful and colorful
story about Boyhood and it is told with
an infinite amount of tenderness please
welcome director Lucas donks
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
hi everyone
we feel incredibly lucky to be here
among five films that each in their own
way talk about us humans
our paradoxes and our consistencies
our longing for intimacy for Magic
for a place that feels like we can
invent ourselves
a place where we can contain multitudes
thank you to all the Europeans who went
out to see these films
the attempts to connect to every
individual audience member is our true
desire our motor in life
the ceremony comes at a strange moment
in time for us as very recently
two screenings of clothes in Bulgaria
were unable to continue due to protests
in Sophia people with hurtful anti-lgbt
IQ plus lures entered the cinema Hall
and started to take pictures of film
goers
for security reasons
and the screening needed to be canceled
in Varna the same thing happened a
couple of days later
you have been thinking about the
Bulgarian audience who tried to see the
film but couldn't
who they are
what they look like
what it feels like to be in a European
country we're watching a film about male
tenderness suddenly feels unsafe
we've been thinking about our audience
in Hungary too
in June 2021 the Hungarian Parliament
created a law that censors the lgbtiq
plus communities in the country
this anti-lgbt propaganda law bans the
depiction of queer people and topics in
the media almost everywhere where kids
could be
on radio and TV you can't hear or see
anything that addresses queer topics
before 10 pm
full team behind close wants to express
their supports to the European
commission who has decided to bring
Hungary in front of the European court
of justice as their law goes against the
most fundamental European norms and
values
[Applause]
we would like
we would like to ask the commission to
consider taking similar actions against
Italy and its prime minister Georgia
Maloney's anti-lgbt IQ plus stance
foreign
rights are Universal and alienable
indivisible interdependent and
interrelated
to all our audiences to all the kids who
deserve to see stories that represent
them
we stand by you as you like every single
human being have the right to be and
discover who you are and who you want to
be
whoever wherever
we think of you and we are hopeful and
proud thank you
[Applause]
our fourth the fourth nominee tonight is
triangle of sadness which was made in
Sweden Germany France and the UK it's a
wild comedy by director Reuben osland
it's taking place on a cruise ship with
influencers and extravagantly rich
people and where a crazy accident is
going to reshuffle the whole social
class system please welcome Sunny males
yes actress in Triangle of sadness
[Music]
throwing away their lives on stupid and
pointerest jobs
can I get you anything to drink
I don't know I was just born into this
life it was not my fault and when this
happened I I just felt like why why
yeah we are all equal
that is so true everyone's equal
thank you
[Music]
Madame President dear members of the
European Parliament medium
dear audience
good evening
what an honor
is it for me as an artist to express my
thoughts
to you here in the European Parliament
in this house
of democracy and the freedom of thought
five nominated film reflect diversity of
life choses that are under the legal
protection
against discrimination decided by the
European Parliament
our nominated film triangle of sadness
of Francis or filter
tells a story about
the interaction between different social
classes
the roles
we act to play in Triangle of sadness
deal with abuse power and money
but our movie
doesn't judge those who are rich or poor
good or evil
just or unjust
in our
humorous and contrite the poetic way the
film allows us to realize that we
as humans are basically
alike at our core we are led to feel
hope in spite of
all our thoughts to make us better
people
yes and sometimes it's enough
if we just go to the movie
if Value Cinema
should go to the cinema
[Applause]
you know what I I wouldn't be standing
here
in front of you in the European
Parliament representing our film
triangle of sadness if not the wonderful
brilliant and unique writer and director
Reuben eslund
always told us his best time is working
intensively with us
with us actors
he encouraged you to be brave
and to fail
in order
to be truthful
unexpected moments arise
and you grow Beyond yourself
for that I thank you Reuben from the
bottom of my heart
not to forget the producer Eric
hammondoff he was still a product of
Philippe as well as my esteemed acting
colleagues and the whole team
of triangle of sadness
and I want to thank also this wonderful
team who did this wonderful evening
because it's for me
and for all the nominated film
the important
prize of democracy
we have to support with this prize all
films
who are not allowed
to do what we think
[Applause]
Willa the Wisp is a Portuguese film
co-produced with France and it is a
playful and bold fantasy
where a king remembers his youth where
firefighters dance
and Love and Desire transcend the screen
it is a modern audacious and
exhilarating Tale
and we'd like to please welcome director
Joe Pedro Rodriguez
[Applause]
[Music]
tomorrow morning
um ladies and gentlemen honorable
members of the European Parliament good
evening
I'm here with my partners
he's sitting there screenwriter and art
director and production designer of my
film folk fatula the Wisp
so we and I arrived yesterday in
Brussels from Kiev in Ukraine where we
were invited for the first ever queer
film festival in Ukraine which goes by
the lovely name of Sunny Bunny
Sunny Bunny was held symbolically for
the first time during the Russian
invasion of Ukraine
doesn't mean the Ukrainian situation in
terms of lgbtq I write plus is good
the festival got a number of threats on
social media
on the opening day a sticker stating
that homophobia is normal appeared on a
pole close to the cinema and three
people were arrested
last Friday five minutes before the end
of the screening of Willow the Wisp the
air ride alarm sounded
we thought the film would be interrupted
but nobody left the cinema
the film ended
there were laughs and Applause
people left the cinema they had to go to
a bomb shelter
unfortunately there was no q a
sometime after the all clear siren
arrived and we could relax
it was time to go home to follow the
midnight curfew
that same night at 220 the air raid
alarm sounded again
this time the debris of a Russian
missile intercepted by the Ukrainian
Army hit an apartment building
three people were killed several were
injured
in our hotel we heard the explosions
in Ukraine the film would not have been
shown if it wasn't for sunny bunny Film
Festival
but because of the looks audience award
nomination my film Willow the Wisp was
subtitled in every language of the EU
and shown in every state member
democracy and civil rights are fragile
we should fight for them every day thank
you
foreign
[Applause]
important and inspiring words thank you
but um so how about we get this trophy
handed Ellie did you know that it's
beautiful shape actually has a meaning
it represents a positive version of the
Babel Tower even though EU citizens
don't speak the same language they share
common values and the idea of the trophy
is to symbolize multilingualism and
cultural diversity in Europe but also
like European films to be a mirror of
European values and social topics that's
why the film rule is with mirror silver
oh okay it's very clear now thank you so
much so I have information too did you
know that it was made by two people it
was made by designer Chris the Becker
and by artists and Creator Jocelyn
caster and Jasleen Caster is here with
us tonight thank you
congratulations
[Applause]
and now before we move to the
announcement of the winner let's watch
one more video a one minute video about
past editions of the Luxe audience award
[Music]
s
no surprise is awarded too
thank you
thank you very much
[Music]
I'm very happy to be a European
filmmaker because I can be German and
part of something bigger at the same
time
I truly hope that you will remember your
nomination for the last audience award
as something unique in a prolonged
cinematic career going forward
[Music]
thank you
all right are you ready I think the
moment we've all been waiting for is
finally arrived so I would like to
invite very soon vice president Regner
to join us to announce the winner
yes can you feel the tension Rising the
same I'm feeling I can barely breathe
good I think we are sisters tonight
perfect great drum rolls please can we
bring the Browns
good
[Music]
Ness
well I know it already and you in a
second so there is the magic moment and
the winner is close
[Applause]
thank you
very good again
I've been joined by chair for Ryan of
the cultural and community and of the
community on culture and education
[Applause]
a picture picture with everyone come to
the center
picture because I'm
[Applause]
and now thank you since the Lux audience
award is a collaboration between MEPS
and citizens uh chair overheim will now
be joined by four EU citizens to honor
the four other films as well as the
representatives of the fields please
join us back please come come join
foreign
[Applause]
with everyone so we take the perfect
perfect amazing so for for
um burning days we have an award that
needs to yes for burning days
perfect
[Music]
picture picture
and now for alcaraz
yes perfect
[Applause]
[Music]
for triangle of sadness
[Applause]
and for Willow the Wisp
[Music]
and now one final big family picture
before we get to the speech of our
winner please one family picture all
together can you see them aren't they
beautiful
[Music]
it looks like the photographers are
ready okay they are thank you very much
thank you all so much
and now
[Music]
[Applause]
and now the speech from our winner close
Lucas don't oh clothes
thank you thank you
you can stand here next to me oh okay
wow
um I just speeched do you have anything
no okay I can't improvise
um thank you
um thank you what was it 45
000 people who voted
um even if you didn't vote for us thank
you we're in the center of democracy so
we have to respect that
um
uh thank you for supporting European
Cinema there are five films here and it
has been said they're all incredible but
there are hundreds and hundreds and
thousands of filmmakers all across
Europe who aren't here today tonight
um support their films as well go to
your local Cinema support their work
ask your representatives to support
their work
because it's important as well so um
thank you thank you Lucas as well thank
you yes thank you well done no yeah I uh
no thank you indeed like Angelo said I
agree with with what he said I want to
thank everyone here and I want to thank
all the European uh audience who went to
see these films during one of the 500
screenings and who voted it feels
incredible and I'm sure I talk for the
others to feel that support from our
European audience so thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
photo again
is it one last picture one last little
picture
yes but thank you thank you to the Lucas
don't and Angelo Angelo Tysons is co
-script writer and before we move to our
clothing musical piece two very
important messages first one being the
new edition of the Lux audience award
will be launched at the Venice film
festival in September where five new
amazing nominees will be announced so
follow the Lux Awards on socials stay
tuned to watch rate and participate
because the next Edition will end in
March 2024 right before the European
elections in June and before we finish
we'd like to thank the interpreters all
of them for making sure that this
ceremony was available to all EU
citizens thank you
[Applause]
so we're gonna close just like we
started with music please remain here in
your seats as we welcome
playing violin and camisa girls playing
cello
and maybe some of you will recognize the
piece they're about to play because it's
the love theme from the Italian classic
chinema Paradiso by Enya moricone
thank you all and good night
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
questions